6 24 good morning
many women are postponing their annual
health screenings including mammograms
for fear of covid but as denise valdez
tells us in today's buddy check report
even just skipping one year can allow an
aggressive cancer to go unchecked
breast cancer is one of the most
preventable cancers as long as it's
caught early but as we enter another
year of the pandemic health experts warn
not to delay your mammogram
mortality rates have been cut 30 percent
through these annual screenings but if
women wait the concern is that as women
go back to screening they're going to
find later stage breast cancer and we're
going to have a lower survival rate
cassie goodman is the early detections
manager for the nevada cancer coalition
she says nearly 70 percent of nevadans
are getting an annual mammogram which is
about the national average but the fear
is that number will drop in the coming
years nevada had an increase in
screening mammograms
from 2018 to 2020
however it doesn't show the full impact
of the pandemic yet beyond covid about a
third of women face some sort of barrier
preventing mammograms losing a job and
health insurance is a big challenge
another obstacle transportation is a big
one that we see because
yeah we have a lot of rural and frontier
communities in nevada and they don't all
have imaging facilities where they are
that's why the mammovan is key
crisscrossing the state bringing
screenings into communities and there
are a number of low cost options
available to women too and remember this
just because you don't have a family
history of breast cancer doesn't mean
you should forego your mammogram in fact
85 percent of breast cancers are found
in women who don't have a family history
so go ahead call your buddy today and
schedule your screening back to you
denise thank you very much 6 26 on a
friday morning